por décimo quinto sábado seguido los
israelíes han salido a las calles al
grito de democracia para manifestarse
contra la reforma judicial una propuesta
que la coalición extremista de netanyahu
se ha visto obligada a posponer
temporalmente aquí en Jerusalén la
marcha la movilización se ubica en la
casa del presidente israelí Isaac gersox
quien ha recibido varias veces a los
representantes de la coalición y de la
oposición para avanzar en una reforma
más consensuada Aunque recién la próxima
semana ambas partes discutirán por
primera vez detalles concretos de los
proyectos de ley que hasta ahora han
sido presentados en el parlamento sin
embargo los manifestantes desconfían
temen que los diálogos sean una
distracción para reducir estas protestas
y por eso se han convocado en 150 puntos
de Israel con un evento principal en la
ciudad de tel aviv se espera que más
allá de los resultados de los diálogos
estos proyectos de ley no sean a priori
tratados en la que en Excel durante mayo
porque el gobierno de netan Yahoo se
enfocaría en conseguir la aprobación de
los presupuestos que son un paso
esencial para evitar que haya una
disolución de su gobierno por otro lado
la impopular reforma ha mostrado esta
semana dos Consecuencias negativas más
una encuesta del Canal 12 local reveló
que sólo un 52% de los votantes del
partido del licut de netanyahu volverían
a votar por él mientras que la agencia
de calificación moodys rebajó la
perspectiva crediticia de Israel de
positiva a estable alimentando un temor
de un impacto económico si el gobierno
sigue adelante con los cambios